foreign
they can Bang the Drum but who will
listen
today there were different messages
outside each government Department
against coal development
water pollution
oil exploration
we're here outside the department for
Net Zero and energy security because
although this department keeps changing
their name they're not changing what
they actually do inside and what we want
to ask them to do is the same thing that
environmentalists have been asking them
to do since the year I was born which is
to stop the expansion of the oil and gas
we know threats human survival
the climate activist's message is
familiar but this is a new tactic more
speeches less super glue discourse not
disruption this is about encouraging
allcomers to the cause
I'm surprised uh at this at the people
who are coming down in a way because
when we started XR you know I expected a
lot of my friends and family to show up
and this time the invitations landed and
loads of those people who I was
surprised weren't coming are all showing
up and we've got over 200 organizations
backing it so it's good
foreign
organizer's Extinction Rebellion says
this weekend we shouldn't expect the
stop oil style tactics of shocking
stunts like the one this week at the
world snooker championships considered a
turn off to many for example XR promised
not to disrupt the London Marathon
writers such as zadie Smith spoke all
these scientists repeating inconvenient
facts
and Brian Eno record producer for U2 and
Coldplay also joined the cause we think
that there's a crisis and our government
apparently doesn't think there's a
crisis it's just not taking the matter
seriously at all I keep saying to
everybody we're all on the same side in
this just that some people haven't yet
realized and the government
unfortunately are at the head of those
people who haven't yet realized
even without arrests there's still drama
in the way they deliver their message
but many of their demands come with
consequences and tough decisions for any
government grappling with high energy
prices inflation and a cost of living
crisis but they say in the face of a
climate crisis the silence is deafening
Jason Farrell Sky News